so if you have concerns that the u.s
intel
agencies which are vast and very
powerful can listen to anything they
want including your private
communications
are out of control and operating in
effect as their own countries you'll be
reassured by people who live in
washington that actually
the constitution gives them oversight
in the form of the congress the congress
oversees the intel agency and they do it
through a committee in the house
and a committee in the senate the
intelligence committees
but take a close look at who sits on
those committees in the house
the house intelligence committee has a
man called eric swawwell he's a member
of congress from the bay area
who we know has had sex with a chinese
spy called fang fang
and yet he remains on the intel
committee
does that shake your faith a little bit
well it turns out according to new
reporting from breitbart news
that there is a classified report that
describes in some detail
apparently eric swalwell's relationship
with that chinese spy
but it remains classified the bide
administration won't reveal it
alex marlowe is the editor-in-chief of
breitbart news he joins us tonight
with this story alex thanks so much for
coming on and congratulations
on breaking this story so eric swalwell
had sex with the chinese spy that's not
just speculation that is known and
apparently the u.s intel agencies know
it now he's supposed to oversee
them but they have a classified report
on him
where does this leave us yeah tucker
last night matt boyle our washington
political editor for breitbart news
broke what are pretty explosive details
about not just swalwell's sex life but
the way
our house intelligence committee is
actually compromised now we knew fang
fang
was infiltrating operations within the
united states various offices and having
relationships with up-and-coming
politicians
before before she abruptly left the
country a few years ago
and we knew she had a intimate
relationship with swalwell we just
didn't know the extent to which
it was intimate well now apparently we
do according to this report which as of
now
swalwell hasn't denied tucker this is
deep penetration
inside the swalwell operation by the
chinese government
yeah i would i would say that by the way
we asked directly asked congressman
swalwell
uh to come on and comment on this it
sets up a very
i think uncomfortable and bad dynamic if
i'm your
boss but you have information on my
weird sexual proclivities
i'm not really your boss anymore you
have power over me and that's kind of
what it looks like here the intel world
knows the details of suawell's
sexual relationship with the chinese spy
but he's supposed to be overseeing them
like that is not the way it's supposed
to work is it
isn't the russian word for that
compromise i remember that from a couple
of years back
yes and as far as we know the only
reason to keep this report a secret to
keep it classified
is to protect eric swalwell's feelings
or maybe to save face for pelosi
and adam schiff the chair of the
committee who's covered for swalwell
this entire time
this is not a joke talker this is a
deeply compromised individual and we
don't know the extent to which he's been
compromised
or if there are other spies out there
are there other members of the intel
committee who've had sex with chinese
spies or do we believe it's only eric
swalwell
that's the question how would we know
because they won't come clean with us in
terms of
who is on these committees and how much
detail is known
not just by our own intelligence
agencies by the way who sort of stumbled
upon this story
but how much information do people like
fang fang knows known communist spies
have about our congress people i agree
with that completely the by
administration should declassify this
immediately
i think to restore our faith in the
system which is rapidly ebbing obviously
alex marlow i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you for that report thanks
tucker